vous êtes vous fait votre cinéma vous
êtes en tournée avec votre spectacle
j'aimerais vous faites beaucoup d'une
imitation de votre spectacle
j'aimerais que vous me disiez ce que
pense fabrice luchini d ombre rouge qui
va passer dans un instant sur son chéri
je vais te dire un truc contrairement au
titre les ombres rouge c'est absolument
ma un spectacle communiste et simplement
la mort qui a rendez-vous sous le soleil
étincelant la méditerranée car si dieu
est à vous la syrie est hanouna
mais saviez vous assurer à tous les dix
mètres se seraient ils ont brossé un
petit peu comme si on en avait cassé la
la biscotte de nadia farès et confitures
coupable c'est qu'ils coupent c'est
peut-être benjamin ou valérie enfin
voilà c'est ça roskill et bouvier
membres qui vient mon coco à mon chéri
chador nous embrassant la il dirait quoi
charles aznavour charles a développé
direct il adore la a fait beaucoup cyril
j'aime beaucoup beaucoup d'élèves j'aime
beaucoup aussi cette série parce que
d'abord c'est pas une série c'est
quelque chose c'est une cyril bien plus
la famille est un peu bohème ce qui me
plaît beaucoup d'ailleurs je suis je
suis venu cela et canadien pour chanter
chez nous la touche x mon poste il faut
regarder cette série
elles vont le mettre en appétit jusqu'au
bout de la nuit
avec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]